Trascrizione: Francesca Salute
Revisore: Piero Cavallo
Mi dite cosa sa fare un bambino?
Oltre che piangere, giocare,
mettere in disordine, sporcare.
Qualche altra idea?
Nessuna?
Ve lo dico io.
Un bambino può insegnare.
In particolare, un bambino
può insegnare ad un adulto tre cose:
essere felice senza alcun motivo
in ogni occasione,
essere sempre impegnato in qualcosa,
e cercare di ottenere qualunque cosa
che sia oggetto del proprio desiderio.
Quindi se un bambino può insegnare
qualcosa, perché non può farlo ragazzo?
Nessuno è inutile in questo mondo,
se ha la capacità di far pesare meno
qualcosa a un altro uomo.
Ad esempio, un ragazzo
sa smorzare i momenti di panico,
oppure dire qualcosa di divertente
durante i momenti difficili.
Sa essere creativo, sa essere testardo,
oppure sa farsi trascinare.
Questo basta per volere qualcosa?
Ma partiamo dall'inizio.
Dalla comune concezione per cui i giovani
sono apatici e menefreghisti.
Anni e anni trascorsi a sentire
il peso del tempo che passa
e del futuro che arriva.
Responsabilità che si accumulano
e persone che continuano imperterrite
ad associarci a nullafacenti,
schiavi dei social network
e strafottenti per ciò che può accadere.
La nostra è un’età
considerata impermeabile
ai sentimenti che i grandi
provano e hanno provato.
Quindi molto spesso sentiamo dirci:
“Non sai veramente cos’è la vita,
il dolore non sai cosa sia”.
Oppure: “La scuola è una passeggiata”.
“Voglio vedere cosa riuscirai a concludere
quando dovrai cercare un lavoro”.
Oppure ancora: “Ma non fai mai niente,
com’è possibile che tu sia stanco?“.
Ora vogliamo raccontarvi due storie.
Quella di Pietro e di Nunzia.
Pietro, una persona che ha sempre vissuto
della propria passione,
che ha viaggiato per tutto il mondo
insieme a sua moglie
e che ha vissuto in Germania
per più di trent’anni.
Fino a quando, però,
sua moglie viene a mancare.
E di conseguenza insieme a lei,
anche la sua autosufficienza.
Questo perché a Pietro un giorno
viene diagnosticato il Parkinson.
Quindi si ritrova spaesato, rimasto solo,
senza la sua compagna di vita.
E senza la sua macchina da cucire.
Perché Pietro è un maestro sarto,
colui che dirige
e mette in pratica le proprie idee.
Colui che concretizza le proprie idee
partendo da un semplice bozzetto.
Pietro ritorna nella sua città natale,
in Italia.
Però molte cose sono cambiate,
e anche lui.
Ho avuto la fortuna di conoscere Pietro
durante un'attività di volontariato.
E la sua storia mi ha insegnato tanto.
Sono riuscita a supportarlo
nei suoi momenti di fragilità
e nella sua quotidianità.
Stravolta, da un giorno all’altro,
da questi ragazzi
che lui chiama boy scout.
Nunzia, invece,
è una ragazza piena di vita,
con la passione per la scrittura,
solare, che un giorno ha segnato
la nostra vita.
Succede che Nunzia si ritrova catapultata
in una realtà
un po’ troppo grande per lei,
una realtà fatta di continui spostamenti,
continue terapie, continui sacrifici.
Nunzia è stata per noi quel bambino,
citato all’inizio,
che ci ha insegnato qualcosa
tramite il suo percorso.
Un percorso durante il quale il nostro
tentativo di sostenerla si è tradotto
in un supporto anche per noi.
Quella strada alla fine l’ha portata
lontana da noi, ma nonostante ciò,
lei ci ha insegnato l’insostenibile forza
del sostegno reciproco.
Queste storie sono tanto lontane,
quanto vicine,
perché, sebbene la differenza d’età
tra Pietro e Nunzia sia enorme,
il supporto viaggia sempre sulla
stessa lunghezza d’onda.
E non ha limiti.
Pietro, che con i suoi 80 anni,
sogna ancora di cucire,
dalla camera della sua casa di riposo.
E Nunzia, che con i suoi 18 anni,
ci fa ancora sognare,
attraverso il suo ricordo
e le sue lezioni di vita.
Perché il supporto viaggia sempre
sulla stessa lunghezza d'onda.
Ma siete sicuri che lo stesso valga
nei confronti dei più giovani?
Noi abbiamo tanto da dare, ma la mancanza
di supporto da parte degli adulti,
coloro che dovrebbero essere
il nostro punto di riferimento,
non fa altro che rallentare
il nostro percorso di crescita
che dovrebbe realizzarsi
in maniera sana e serena.
È vero, non possiamo aspettarci
dei cambiamenti nella società,
se non siamo disposti e pronti
a metterci in gioco per ottenerli.
Quello che chiediamo,
è che dall’altra parte
venga ascoltata la nostra voce.
Senza alcun pregiudizio.
Dare voce.
Solo così si potrà capire
quanto sia fondamentale la giovinezza.
Con la sua sensibilità.
Una risorsa per tutti.